how do you find the mentor so I got a
great question for my youtube viewers
Tom love you guys who wrote in to say
how do you find the mentor this is a
great question and one that a lot of
entrepreneurs a ski you know you realize
you can't do everything yourself and you
don't need to come up with every single
new idea yourself if you have somebody
who has already done it and leverage
what they've learned to help you grow
its way faster to achieve your goal than
to try to figure it all out yourself in
my mind there are two types of mentors
and you can leverage both to help you
grow your business the first people are
what I call aspirational mentors they're
people who you never meet but can still
give you lots of great advice so my
first aspirational mentor was Bill Gates
I had a software company Bill Gates was
the biggest guy in software I never met
bill gates the Bill Gates saved my
company okay I was gonna quit I was I
told my business partner that I quit I
was in tears I thought of giving up I
thought I had tried everything and I
started researching Bill Gates I realize
you know what I'm not the first guy to
try to sell software and I research Bill
Gates in his story and how he started
Microsoft and how he built his business
up and a lot of it was through
partnerships and so I applied that same
strategy apart of my business and within
a couple months i got my first deal the
first year was 13 and a half thousand
dollars and not that like that saved my
business i was making 300 bucks a month
and here was a 13 and a half thousand
dollar order it was amazing i mean i
seem like a lot to you guys now but that
that changed my life and then I was able
to close another deal on another deal
another deal and that was all because of
Bill Gates and I had never met him I
just researched his story I now I look
up to AP Giannini who is a founder bank
of america and steve jobs to the front
of apple and these guys teach me things
AP patines AP Giannini he's been dead
for years and Steve Jobs I'll you know
recently passed away I've never met
these people but they're impacting my
business and I consider them my mentors
so what
but you're trying to do find someone
who's already done it and research their
success the bigger they are the easier
it is to find out what their story is so
the second kind of mentor is actually
somebody you can talk to write some you
can go have a coffee with and bounce
ideas off of the challenge for a lot of
entrepreneurs is they go up to people
and say hey will you be my mentor and
right away you freak people out you know
it's like asking somebody off the street
will you marry me it doesn't happen
mentorship is a relationship you have to
get to know each other you have to work
well together you have to have trust you
have to build that up it's not something
you just jump into so if you want
somebody to mentor you don't don't email
them and say will you be my mentor
because it's too much of an ask the
better thing to do is connect with
somebody and ask them for for 20 minutes
of their time awesome for a phone call
for a coffee show your interest because
people like helping other people if you
have a passion and you seem really
excited and interested in learning then
people will want to help you out mentors
gain as well we feel good giving advice
to mentees if if we feel like that
person is actually going to go and do
something with it right they're going to
take that knowledge and apply it and if
I get that for people who write to me if
I get that sense of excitement and
passion and and willingness to follow
through that I'm happy to help them out
but it starts by building a relationship
so 20 minutes over coffee I remember I
had one person right into means and say
I want to meet with you even if it's
walking with you on the way to a meeting
let me know I'll bring you some cookies
and we'll chat on the walk right that
shows drive and determination and so let
that come out when you're approaching
people and have a simple ask and after
that 20 minutes if your passion comes
through and they are feeling your vibe
and feel like you're taking their advice
it's usually pretty easy to say hey
would you mind if I if I called you back
in a month if I had more questions going
to reach out to you almost everybody's
going to say yes unless your total
douche bag you know in the meeting and
super early because you're not
respecting their time
then they're going to say yes and that
starts the relationship and it can build
to something more right but you got to
start it off small and simple and easy
make it easy for people to say yes and
not throw this huge commitment in front
of them so if you know somebody who
you're trying to target right that you
know there's somebody you have in mind
who's this big shot or whoever it is
then you can reach out to them with
something simple like that and let your
passion shine through and in one of my
mizuka guides on finding a mentor I have
a script that you can use as an email
template to connect with people if you
don't know who you want to connect with
you don't have an idea of the person
that you want to go to then start
reaching out to your network ID let them
know who you're looking for the first
mentor that I had the real mentor was a
guy by the name of John and I found
jamba going to my bank because I I had
no connections I was 19 I had no
connections you know I didn't want to
ask my parents I wanted to you know feel
like I'm doing this myself and not being
supported because you know my mom's
friend is helping me and I had no
personal connections my friends are all
in school right so I went to the bank I
thought the bank is gonna be a friend of
entrepreneurs that's obviously not what
the bank does is giving advice but they
connected me with somebody named Michael
who i thought you know great Michael
this guy's got this downtown office and
you know nice views of the city and
looks like a really big big guy a big
shot and he was just all air he was all
air but he introduced us to another guy
named Steve who tried to help us out but
couldn't and he introduced us to another
friend named John and John ended up
being an awesome force for our company
and taught us and trained us and gave us
lots of advice and ended up helping us
sell our business and so such a strange
paths but that's how it builds right I
spoke to my bank I had no contact say I
just walked into my bank and then they
put me on the somebody put me on to
somebody and get put me on to John and
and it may happen faster for you but
it's put in that message out there to
your contacts to your network or the
type of person you're looking for and
setting up times to go meet people
so that's my advice find your aspiration
lament or find someone who's done what
you're trying to do and research how
they got started and then for an actual
you know in person human that you can
talk to make it simple easy low-risk 20
minutes over coffee show your passion
let that shine through and if you don't
know anybody yet to go after start
putting out to your connections your
network or the type of person you're
looking for and the venture will come if
you have persistence that's how you find
a mentor believe for those are watching
I love to hear in the comments leave a
comment as to how you found your mentor
how you looking for a mentor who your
mentors are I love to hear from you in
the comments below if you like these
videos you can click on the link to
support me in the description and click
on my face here to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon